transparent people are absolutely going
crazy for this show and it is also a
show that is tackling one of the major
issues in our country and in the world
right now with those people wrestling
with their gender their gender
identifications that clear on and this
so you must be getting a lot of intense
reaction on this role I get three
reactions one reaction is you know I
didn't know what to expect - the second
reaction is Jill Soloway has created one
of the great great things with and the
third is people stop and talk to me and
they start telling me about transgender
experiences and their family or things
that have happened in their family or
indeed just about their family so
something is going on and I've always
thought that humor and laughter was
healing I always have and I think it's
important so I'm the luckiest guy in the
room there's no doubt about it
what's your getting people people
obviously want to talk about it and the
show gives them a way to laugh right
also it brings up the discussion
absolutely and you know I have I have
kids I have you know I have a daughter
in her late thirties she's 40 and I have
two five-year-old twins and their world
is changing I mean it's a different
gender is being rediscovered the we have
a clip Oh from transparent and I
mentioned this to you one of the things
that I really appreciate about the show
is we live in such a fast cutting
culture yeah a lot of your performances
they really let you your character and
you sort of marinate they let they take
their time do they take their time and
they let you as an artist figure out
right what it is you want to do and they
don't rush it that's Jill Soloway she's
the supreme artist of artists hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please